if the separation of church and state
ever existed in the state of new york
that distinction has been obliterated by
the empire state's new governor kathy
hokel who demands that her constituents
take the coronavirus vaccine and
justifies her demand as an edict from
god himself
we are not through this pandemic i
wished we were but i prayed a lot to god
during this time
and you know what god did answer our
prayers he made the smartest men and
women the scientists the doctors the
researchers he made them come up with a
vaccine that is from god to us
and we must say thank you god thank you
and i wear my vaccinated necklace all
the time to say i'm vaccinated all of
you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants you know this
you know who they are
i need you to be my apostles i need you
to go out and talk about it and say we
owe this to each other we love each
other
which god are we talking about here
because i went to church on sunday i try
to take my faith christianity seriously
and i've never read anything about the
fauchiachi as a requirement of the faith
she says she wears her her vaccination
status on a little necklace you know
christians sometimes wear a crucifix or
a scapular but she wears her vaccination
status christians try to be disciples of
christ follow in the line of the
apostles who are apostles to jesus she
says be apostles
to me
well this this fauciachi this is a
sacrament
not to christians or jews or muslims but
to modern disciples of the cult of
public health of progressivism of
politics
according to these leftists there is no
god but science and fouchy is his
prophet the science of history the
science of politics
she can make these edicts from on high
and people must follow them
now of course these very same people
reject science the moment it involves
biological sex or pre-born babies
governor hochul is very possibly the
most pro-abortion governor in the entire
country
no no the kooky religious talk we're
hearing from people like hokel is less
the doctrine of some new religion of
science than it is the familiar
superstitions of paganism replete with
the same old sort of shamans and even
the child sacrifice
but be not deceived
god is not mocked i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from old school man
that guy has gotten a lot of top
comments on this show he says if the
left actually cared about offering
immigrants asylum due to horrible living
conditions they would be bringing
australians here by the plainful
that's true but you can never help the
west
even the when the west is in the
southeast you can never help western
civilization it's all about uh bringing
other people into our civilization
because our civilization is so rotten
and we've wronged everybody and we're
the cause of all the problems on earth
that's what's going on but i agree those
poor those poor australians need some
asylum you know
they need to hire better politicians
over in that country when you want to
hire better people i would strongly
recommend you check out ziprecruiter
businesses are trying to find workers
these days and it's not so easy to do it
all these businesses reopening means
that millions of jobs need to be filled
where do these businesses turn to fill
those roles fast
it's a recruiter right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com knowles
when you post a job to zip recruiter
it's not just throwing spaghetti at a
wall okay they actively go out they send
your job to over 100 top job sites they
give you access to their network of
millions of job seekers you review
recommended candidates that they go out
and find you you invite your top choices
to apply for your job which is
encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates
head on now check it out zip recruiters
tech is so effective that four out of
five employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day right now you can try sip recruiter
for free at
knowles that is zipruder.com
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
governor hocal in new york really creepy
stuff from her
i have long said
quoting cardinal manning that all
politics all human conflict ultimately
is theological all politics boils down
ultimately to religion because we're
talking about morality we're talking
about ethics we're talking about the
relationship of man to his community and
to his state and to his god his place in
the universe so obviously it's going to
eventually come down to religion but
this lady's taking it to a really crazy
extreme
wearing her vaccination status like some
kind of religious totem
meanwhile
she's firing
hospital staff
we're told that we need the hospital
staff
we're told that these are the most
wonderful people in new york these are
the heroes more heroic than the firemen
on 9 11 the nurses and doctors who you
know treated people with the wuhan cough
but now
after hearing that for 18 months
we are being told that the hospital
workers are going to be fired because
some of them don't want to take the
fouchy algae we'll be nation leading
with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in a
hospital in the state of new york or
healthcare facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people uh who've been retired who
may have had a licensed lapse bring in
people from elsewhere that is not my
first position that my friends my my my
desire is to have the people who've been
out there continue to work in their jobs
working them safely and to all the other
health care workers who are vaccinated
they also deserve to know that the
people they're working with will not get
them sick
so we're told that the hospitals are
overflowing we need all hands on deck
and we're also told that if you don't
get the the shot then we're going to
fire you why do you need to get the shot
because people need to come in and get
their booster shots why do they need to
get their booster shots because the
vaccine apparently wasn't as effective
as we were told that it was in the first
place so then why do you need to get the
vaccine hospital workers well because
it's so extremely effective
uh huh what
are you sure about that
well don't worry there's no reason to
hesitate to get the vaccine because the
vaccine is extremely safe
okay well uh what's the evidence that
the vaccine is safe well the the vaccine
is so safe that the fda won't approve
the booster shots that we all said that
we need because the vaccine isn't as
effective as we told you it was in the
first place
huh what it's not making a whole lot of
sense to me
it's not making a lot of sense to me
either
this is
an exercise as it's been from the
beginning but it's getting clearer by
the day this is an exercise in political
power there's not a lot of reason to it
people from the beginning have been
comparing the
coronavirus the covid the public health
dictatorship to a sort of religious
apparatus i've made this comparison
before but
the difference here is that true
religion
is reasonable
these people are not reasonable they're
changing their story every single day
and they are capriciously wielding
power
now
this is sick stuff obviously it shows
you how disingenuous the left was when
they were
extolling the virtues of the healthcare
workers and saying they don't care about
the healthcare workers they care that
people do what they tell them to do and
the minute the healthcare workers don't
do what they tell them to do they fire
them they put them out of a job the
greatest heroes in the world for 18
months sorry you're on
you're on your rear end in the middle of
the street
now why are people going into the
hospitals
it's not because they have covet
necessarily
a lot of people are coming down with
covid symptoms and they think they have
covid but they're testing negative for
covid
this was a headline just came out from
uh from the
daily mail
so the the headline is why are so many
suffering dreadful covid symptoms but
still testing negative
sarah vine was convinced she had it but
countless tests said otherwise and she's
far from alone what is going on
let's go let's use is it some grand
conspiracy
and is it there's the conspiracy
regarding the tests or is it
is it because kovid for the vast
majority of people is just a cough and a
headache
and
the covet is not the only disease that
will give you a cough and a headache
it's we used to call that a cold
or the flu or any other number of
ailments
and people get sick by the way people
can get i know this is shocking people
can get sick and have it not be the
coronavirus
they're they're all it's weird because
the flu basically disappeared last year
everyone had the coronavirus but nobody
had the flus pretty strange but people
can get sick and you know what it's okay
to get
mildly sick it's okay it's a normal
thing
it's not going to end the world if you
come down with the sniffles
you'll be fine
we have immune systems
i know that we pretend that we don't
anymore we have natural immunity to
certain things that we have experienced
before i know that we pretend that
that's not true anymore
but it's okay this virus has turned the
society
so much more neurotic than it already
was and it already was pretty bad they
just don't understand it how could
people be coming down with the sniffles
but they don't have kovid
now because there are other viruses and
maybe if you're confusing your common
cold with kovid
maybe kovid wasn't as bad as everyone
was pretending it was for the vast
majority of people maybe that's the case
i don't know
but the kovid dictatorship marches on
and on and on in in
canada right now the cops are stopping
random people on the street well
actually i should i should not say that
it's not random people they're stopping
a specific type of people and it's not
based on sex and it's not based on race
and it's it's based
much more
on class
you fit a criminal profile today yeah
normally people look down the nosey a
little bit when you wear high views but
um no not like this mate it's uh
yeah it's pretty pretty odd so they're
stopping anyone that obviously looks
like a
construction worker i find myself going
for a walk trying to get back to work so
you're here for a
late lawful reason lawful reasons always
the cops with the guns just one of them
looks at me to sprint across the road
and they just drop me all like five on
top of me just smashing me for no reason
so why they pull you up i just just was
just for being here basically yeah are
you within your 10k yeah i live in south
melbourne i just walked here my watch is
still going 4.2 k's
[Music]
they cuffed me
and then five of them held on to me for
no reason and i said let me go i'm doing
nothing wrong
and then cut it off being profiled
because i'm because i'm wearing my
tradie outfit yeah so this is what's
happening and it's happening throughout
the west
the people who are being targeted here
it's not it's not on their race or on
their sex it's on their class
covid has opened up or really
highlighted a serious class
battle
between the ruling class
and the ruled between the elite people
from the elite institutions
and the ruled who were told to get in
line or lose all their rights and all
their way of life
these sorts of things really make you
want to protect yourself and you want to
protect yourself i would strongly
recommend you check out ring i'm not the
handiest guy in the world okay i don't
think i'm
revealing any previously unknown secrets
and yet even i am able to install ring
your ring alarm is so simple to install
you can do it in a matter of minutes
obviously you can keep an eye on who's
at your doorstep see and speak to
whoever is out there whether you're in
your home whether you're on a beach
whether you're at the office doesn't
matter
you can see every inch of your house on
the inside on the outside of the house
it's really nice especially if you like
me occasionally go on the road you want
to make sure that your wife and your
child are nice and safe and secure gives
you a little bit of peace of mind i
would strongly recommend you protect
your home anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm go to ring
dot com slash knowles canon wles for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today build a system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes that is ring dot com slash
knowles canada
we are told right now
that the the primary divisions in our in
our country
are
uh partisan
they're sexual we're especially told
that they're racial but that's not true
you saw that clip i think i misspoke i
think i said it was from canada it's
from rebel news but it was a clip from
australia you'd probably hear that in
the accents australia is the clearest
example of
of of where the covid lockdown
dictatorship is going crazy but it's
true broadly throughout the west and
it's not breaking down on the sexual or
the racial or the partisan lines
but that is what we are all told to
focus on i'll give you there was
there was another big racial incident
okay this time it was in atlanta
someone painted several racist and
defensive slurs on a building at emory
university in atlanta i've spoken at
emory before it's a pretty left-wing
place
and at the time the local news outlet
wsb-tv
reported that the emory autism center
has become the target of several crimes
including burglary and vandalism
including graffiti of racial slurs and
swastikas
a police report of the incident showed
that vending machines had been
vandalized glass had been shattered
quote the area where racial slurs were
reportedly written along the walls are
near the workspace occupied by two
african-american women a swastika was
found in a hallway near a jewish man's
office
at the time the school says the acts of
racism and anti-semitism are painful for
all of us at the eac and in the emory
community they will not be tolerated and
every effort will be made to bring the
perpetrators
to justice
when i saw this story
without knowing anything else
but i hadn't seen the picture of the guy
who perpetrated it i looked at that i
said that's a hoax
that's a hoax that's not a white
supremacist it's not a neo-nazi
it's a race hoax being perpetrated by
big libs
by left-wingers
very likely by a black guy
you know i hate to say i told you so but
i was right that turns out the
perpetrator is
black he's a black guy i i detail a lot
of these incidents in my book speechless
so many of the high
the majority of the of the highest
profile racial incidents
in recent decades
turned out to be hoaxes
the allegedly oppressed people
were the ones who set the whole thing up
in the first place
why is that well you can see you you see
it in the
the uh
statement given by this by the school
the acts of racism and anti-semitism are
painful for all of us stop it right
there
no they're not they're pleasurable
these are pleasurable incidents
for people who can claim
victimhood and therefore social currency
and for the ruling class that seeks to
divide us these racial incidents these
hoaxes are extremely pleasurable because
it advances their political goals
they're not pain they're painful for the
people who are accused of bigotry and
racism and whose rights and way of life
are being taken away
as a result of that but it's pleasurable
for for the people who who benefit from
it
this is why
they also often turn out to be hoaxes
because there is a real
advantage to being able to claim
victimhood
the culture has gone absolutely crazy on
race it has also gone crazy on sex there
is a
fairly well respected scientific journal
the lancet i quote the lancet and
research from the landsat
often on this show
the lancet just came out with its new
cover for its latest issue
the cover says quote
historically it's just a white
background and then you got the quote on
the cover historically the anatomy and
physiology of bodies with vaginas have
been neglected
what
the conservatives here
are outraged
because the lancet embraces
transgenderism right they're saying well
it's not just women who possess that
body part but it's
it's everybody men
people who identify as men or
non-gendered or this or that or any of
the 57 genders so conservatives are
outraged that the scientific journal
embraces this unscientific concept of
transgenderism
feminists are outraged
that
this journal
seems to erase women right it's no
forget about women it's bodies with this
particular anatomical feature
and furthermore that it defines women by
their anatomy
and how dare you eyes up here buddy i'm
more than just my body parts right the
most shocking part though
is that this journal is defining all of
us
as
bodies this is weird i am not just a
body i can't believe this is really
basic stuff that our culture has gotten
so stupid on that we don't recognize
this anymore
we are more than just our bodies we are
soul and spirit too we're not just meat
puppets we're not just flesh we have
minds
okay you've got the materialist heresy
on one hand which is the the idea that
we're just meat puppets then you've got
the transgender gnostic heresy on the
other the idea that our bodies have
nothing to do with who we are and then
you've got the normal obvious common
sense
true understanding of human nature which
is that we are both you know tony heasy
coates who is an extremely overrated
race hustling author he uh he loves to
use this phrase black bodies he says the
black body is very oppressed as if black
people don't have souls
no it's it's more than that buddy we are
a human person
but because we
are so insanely focused on this stuff on
the on the physical we lose sight of
that this is this is actually it ties in
with the racial thing we're so focused
on on the physical that we think that
racism is the only evil in the world
because our understanding of sin and
grace and morality only goes skin-deep
so the the editor-in-chief of the lancet
came out he's he sort of apologized but
then he defended it because he said
trans people face stigma transgender
health is very important and of course
he doesn't mean
fixing the problem or even acknowledging
it when a man thinks he's a woman or
vice versa he means affirming people in
their delusions this is the state of
modern medical science the religion
that so many leftists ascribe to the
official religion of the state of new
york now where we need apostles of their
religion we need people to wear the
religious totems of that religion
speaking of sex there's a sex story that
came out a few days ago that i didn't
get to but i do i don't want to miss it
i do want to get to it because
it's a weird one chris cuomo has been
accused of sexual harassment
and he's been accused of this in the new
york times and i can't believe it i ah
this is really strange
i have to sort of defend chris cuomo
here
okay so this woman shelly ross who is a
tv journalist and executive producer at
abc and cbs
she is accusing chris cuomo
of greeting her at a party by grabbing
her derriere
in
in 2005. so this is 16 years ago this
woman had been chris cuomo's boss she
had been the the ep on the show
but then she left so she was no longer
his boss and he shows up to this party
one imagines people are throwing back a
few cocktails here and he grabs her in
this kind of grotesque way
he goes up he greets her he grabs her on
the dairy area says now now i can do
this hahaha and she says no you can't
her husband was there and
uh so after this party he apologizes he
sends her an email it says this is from
the article she's acknowledging this now
that i think of it i'm ashamed i
shouldn't have even put you in such a
position uh please apologize to your
very good and noble husband
um please pass along my apology i
apologize to you as well for putting you
in this position next time i'll remember
the lesson no matter how happy i am to
see you my hearty greeting was a
function of being glad to see you but
you know i'm ashamed
maya culpa okay and she obviously
accepted his apology
but now 16 years later she's turning it
on him again this is very cynical it's
very cynical obviously chris cuomo
should not have done it
it's a
boorish barbaric thing to do you should
not greet women this way especially not
when they are married especially not
when you are married okay
nobody says that what he did was right
or that what he did wasn't wrong least
of all chris cuomo who apologized for it
and she
apparently accepted his apology at the
time but now 16 years later she doesn't
like something that he has said or done
and so she comes out and says he
sexually assaulted me
that's not about justice
that's not about
protecting the world from a predator
that's not about showing him the error
of his ways even because he apologized
already you accepted his apology
it's just about
political opportunism
it's just about
finding someone's sin that he's already
apologized for
and and holding it over him
to make him do whatever you want for the
rest of your life and his life
that's not right what a graceless
society we live in if that's if that's
the norm
really bad for society if
every wrong that you have ever committed
and and i'm certain that you like me
have committed many wrongs many sins in
your past
if any of them even the ones that have
been forgiven
can then just be used to
attack you to destroy your career to
even get you thrown in prison or
something you know to get you really
accused of a serious crime
what kind of society are we living in
it's so cheap
the woman essentially admits in this
article yeah it's not really about
justice or
my my feeling of victimhood this is just
about getting chris cuomo because he's
doing things that i don't like that's
ugly stuff and we got to call it out
even when it's
even if it's fredo cuomo even if it's
someone that we generally don't like
very much
you know speaking of
these sorts of issues
if you are
having a little trouble with men's
health i would strongly recommend you go
check out hymns for hymns.com is all
about men's wellness need help with ed
hair loss have a cold
interested in mental health or
coronavirus home tests hymns is here for
you through hymns you can get the
prescription medication that treats ed
real science real solutions to ed you
get the same active ingredient as that
expensive little pill but without the
expensive price tag this could cost
hundreds of dollars if you had to go
through a doctor or a pharmacy
not so with hymns hymns makes it simple
and affordable why live with ed when the
solution can be so
simple take control of your wellness i
know that men don't always like to talk
about these sorts of things well hymns
makes it so
simple easy
try hymns today by going for a free
online visit go to for hims.com michael
for your free visit that is for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s
michael prescription products are
subject to medical provider approval and
require an online consultation with
medical provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see website
for full details and safety information
that is for hims.com
michael also subscribe and start
listening now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcasts leave a five-star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a whole lot more
there are a lot of illegal aliens in the
state of california or at least there
were
but now there aren't any illegal aliens
in the state of california according to
the california legal code this is not
because governor mussolini has deported
all of the foreign nationals in the
country
this is because
he has taken that term illegal alien out
of the state code
newsome says
as the nation's most diverse state
we are stronger and more vibrant because
of our immigrant communities this
important legislation removes the word
alien which is not only an offensive
term for a human being but for far too
long has fueled a divisive and hurtful
narrative by changing this term we are
ensuring california's laws reflect our
state's values
only that last part is true
that last part where they say
by changing the term we now make sure
that the state code reflects our values
the value is we don't have a border and
we're going to flood the country with
foreigners
we'll flood the state with
foreigners but nothing else here is true
as as our nation's most diverse state
we're stronger and more vibrant because
of our immigrant communities so what
they when they say
diversity what they mean is
brought in this case broadly
non-american and specifically non-white
right that that is the way the term is
used on the left and broadly in the
culture and that's a really ugly thing
to say to say that
uh
non-white people
are much stronger than white people we
don't when there are places with white
people that's bad and when there are
places with non-white people that's good
that's an ugly thing to say you might
call that racist that's an ugly thing to
say
next he says
this this important legislation removes
the word alien which is an offensive
term for a human being it's not an
offensive term for a human being it's a
very simple clinical term that means
foreign a foreigner
you're an alien
and it's fueled divisive and hurtful
narratives
it's racist
no it's not it's clear language
for a foreigner but now when those terms
are taken away they'll be replaced by
terms like migrant
this is far less clear language because
there are legal migrants and illegal
migrants
that distinction is being obliterated in
this california state code
this is what my book is about this is
what my book speechless is about that
the left believes that by redefining the
words you can redefine reality itself
and as a practical political matter
often that can be very effective
whoever controls the words controls the
debate and so now we're not going to
debate the propriety of having a bunch
of illegal aliens in the state they're
not illegal anymore they're not aliens
at the very least
they're californians they're future
americans
they're just maybe they're undocumented
but sorry we'll get them documents
they're already doing it
very effective strategy and it's not
even the the most cynical thing the
guy's doing in the state right now gavin
newsom
has also just signed legislation making
cheat by mail i'm sorry excuse me vote
by mail a permanent feature of
california elections
he signed assembly bill 37 which
requires a mail-in ballot to be mailed
to every registered voter in the state
this makes the golden state
the eighth state in the country to
implement this sort of law
so there it is it's going to be very
very difficult
with one of the most corrupt rife for
fraud election practices now as a matter
of law in california it's going to be
very very difficult for republicans to
win elections
no less a leftist than barack obama just
just in recent years
pointed out that widespread mail-in
voting
leads to abuse it can lead to
cheating but the democrats run the
entire state
they've got a perfect lock on the state
and so they institute widespread mail-in
votes automatic mail-in votes
very hard to see how the republicans
take power back that's why
a lot of people want to stay and fight
but
you've also got to know when to have a
tactical retreat okay and this is why a
lot of people are fleeing california for
conservative states
because we need to concentrate our
forces where we can win victories if we
want to try to win broader national
victories in the future
this sort of thing should not be
permitted widespread mail in voting it
is just as corrupt as the old political
machines of tammany hall and boss tweed
but that is the law now in california
because elections have consequences
we've got to prevent this in places that
we currently have some control over
speaking of election fraud
here's a story that we're not supposed
to talk about but whatever let's talk
about it let's see
your move social media platforms you can
kick me off if you want but i'm just
going to read the news here
there was a recount there was there was
a
an audit of the recount in arizona okay
and the audit established that there
were no
substantial differences between the hand
count of the ballots and the official
canvas results for the county in the
2020 election
that's the headline that you are going
to see in the news the audit found that
there were no substantial differences
between the hand count of ballots and
the official count for the county that
that resulted in the 2020 election
okay
biden won arizona
by 10
457 votes
okay
what happens beyond the headline
the audit established the hand recount
what happens beyond the headline there
were numerous findings of problems with
the election and evidence indicating
that tens of thousands of ballots were
illegally cast or counted so some of
those ballots should not have been cast
in the first place and some of the
ballots even if they were cast by real
people who were eligible voters should
not have been counted
because they did not follow the rules
for casting the ballots
the review revealed that more than 17
thousand
uh return envelopes were duplicates
maricopa county recorded more than 6545
early voting return envelopes then this
reviewing organization determined
existed and fifteen thousand thirty five
mail-in votes in maricopa county were
from voters who had moved prior to the
registration deadline another
6591 mail in ballots came from voters
who had moved out of arizona prior to
the registration deadline and
1718 mail in votes came from voters who
moved within arizona but out of maricopa
county
prior to the registration deadline a
good reporting on this is in the
federalist right now
so what does this mean which which
headline is to be believed did biden win
arizona or did
did biden maybe not win arizona well yes
it is true that the audit found that the
the
there was no substantial difference
between the hand count of the ballots
and the numbers we were told shortly
after the election
but that's not really the question the
question is how many of those ballots
were eligible to be cast or counted in
the first place
there just this number 17 000 duplicate
images
biden didn't even win the state by 11
000 votes
that seems pretty suspect to me all
those other numbers as well
the media are only the establishment
media are only going to give you that
statement the the wreak the hand recount
and the official numbers after the
election were basically the same okay
but that's not the point
point is how many of those ballots
should have been counted in the first
place and these reviews
suggest to me
that the answer is far from clear
and if it is clear it's maybe clear in a
different direction
i think that this
recount is a vindication of the people
who say that there was a lot of
corruption and there are other numbers
too i'm just giving you the top-line
views there's a lot of other shady stuff
that was discovered in this audit in
this review
i think the people who demanded the
audit and the review were obviously
justified in doing so but one of the
problems with these mail-in ballots is
that
there's very little you can do
it's very it's very difficult to trace
these things to compare these things
it's hard to count them in the first
place that's why we've been so reticent
as a country to use them but now that
democrats think that they can really
count on that advantage they're pushing
them very very hard so what can we do
right now
probably nothing
about the 2020 election nothing really
is the answer
what can we do right now
moving forward well we can in the states
where we have power we can prevent this
kind of stuff from going on
this is something ron desantis is doing
in florida
desantis just directed the secretary of
state laurel m lee to investigate
facebook for election interference
governor santis says
that recent reports showing that
facebook is impacting the results of
state and local elections are quote
an affront to the basic principles of a
republic so he signs this order he says
i hereby direct that your office
immediately investigate this alleged
election interference
caused by facebook through its white
listing program and any other previously
undisclosed undisclosed program within
facebook in order to determine whether
any violations of florida's election
laws took place
the the report that came out showed that
facebook officially does not enforce
some of its rules on some of its people
some elite people get to violate
facebook's community standards and rules
and some people don't
and as we saw during the 2020 election
democrats get favorable treatment that's
just the way it goes and when there are
damaging stories about the biden family
published for instance by the new york
post
those just don't spread on facebook you
don't get to post them you don't get to
privately message them
and that constitutes election
interference facebook and especially
google and to a lesser degree twitter
control the public square what they are
doing is by definition a political act
which means in a country that is
self-governing they control the entire
political order and we cannot permit
that and we need to use state power we
need to use the government
to stop that i know this is going to be
shocking to people who over the past 20
years have been told that the government
is the only threat to our liberty and
we've got to stop big government we've
got to shill for corporations that hate
our guts but that that is the wrong idea
if my rights and my way of life are
being taken away by
some weirdos in silicon valley that does
not make me feel any better than if they
were being taken away by the government
and and the reason we have a political
system is so that we can use the
government for just ends
like for instance preventing weirdos in
silicon valley from controlling our
politics
speaking of florida speaking of justice
it's a sheriff in florida right now
who seems to understand justice pretty
clearly
there is a man who is accused of
attempting to kill a cop and critically
wounding him and he might not survive
he's not expected to survive
and now he's on the loose
and
the sheriff in this town
he said if this
cop killer
tries to break in to your home into your
office
you should
do everything you can to to
de-escalate the situation and you should
take him peacefully into custody and you
should no he didn't say that he said you
should blow him away like a rabid animal
and that's true that's what should
happen quote blow him out the door
because he is like a rabid animal the
sheriff is bill leaper he was referring
to this man patrick renee mcdowell who
according to the northeast florida
fusion center
which is part of the florida department
of law enforcement agencies
he has military training he was in the
marine corps and he shot deputy josh
moyers 29 years old in the face last
friday blow him away
we are told that in order to have
criminal justice reform in this country
which is so sorely needed we need to
go easier on criminals and we need to
let criminals out of prison and we need
to not put them in prison in the first
place and especially if they're black we
need to not arrest them because of
historical blah blah blah whatever and
it's really compassionate to let these
killers
and thugs and criminals just go on the
loose that is not compassionate that's
very cruel that's cruel to all of the
innocent people that these criminals are
going to attack the compassionate thing
here
is to
enact
justice
okay it's much more compassionate to his
potential victims and it's more
compassionate to him this man is not
thriving by killing cops that's not good
for him it's not good for his soul
that's not good for him as a member of
society
it is good
to bring him into line with just we do
need criminal justice reform in this
country
it's not that we have an
over-incarceration problem we have a
significant under-incarceration problem
in this country we need to bring
criminals into
line
speaking of which
speaking of our total confusion on this
on the left and on the right don't
forget it was donald trump who signed
the jailbreak bill okay it was one of
the worst things he did in his
administration overall i thought he was
a terrific president that was one of the
worst things that he did and it shows
you how how deep the rock goes that even
the right believes that we need to let
criminals out of prison that our problem
in this country is we were too tough on
crime
there is a man named john hinckley john
hinckley tried to murder
president reagan
in the 1980s john hinckley did wound
multiple people who were protecting
lincoln and he permanently paralyzed and
shortened the life of ronald reagan's
press secretary
john hinckley
has just been given
unconditional release
tries to kill the president of the
united states
seriously grievously arms lots of other
people now that gets to go free
john hinckley jr the man who tried to
kill reagan won the unconditional
release from his state mandated
supervision on monday the the doj agreed
to a deal with hinckley's attorney
federal judge accepted it
he will live his life without
court-ordered restrictions and mandated
supervision of his doctors hinckley's
attorney says there is no evidence of
danger whatsoever it's a momentous event
this is compassionate isn't it
i don't
i don't know that it's compassionate so
first of all the only reason this could
happen is because hinckley
was uh found criminally insane
so he was it's not that he was just a
criminal he was also insane and so he
didn't go to a normal jail he was
committed to an insane asylum
okay then he's got to stay there he's
lucky he got to avoid jail time but then
he's got to stay in the insane asylum
he's crazy enough to try to kill the
president and he tried to kill the
president because he was in love with
jodie foster
which adds to the kookiness
now we're told it's really compassionate
to let him out it's not compassionate to
let him out he's a nut
by his own admission or his lawyer's own
admission he's not so you the reason we
have insane asylums in the first place
or at least we used to is because it's
not compassionate to let crazy people
live in squalor on their own
you it's not compassionate we should do
this now on the streets of los angeles
in san francisco and new york we let
crazy people live in filth on the
streets and in danger on the streets
that's not compassionate that's cruel
and it's based on the false
understanding of liberty on the left
which says that liberty is just doing
whatever you want but also on the right
so this idea of
leave me alone you do you who cares it's
not my problem if crazy people are going
to live on the street they're a danger
to themselves and to others and they're
going to live in filth that's not my
problem it is your problem you live in
society this is your country what kind
of country do you want to live in
is this is this compassionate to the
family of ronald reagan is this
compassion the family of the people this
guy
did
kill over the long term like brady the
press secretary or to the people that he
grievously injured i don't think so
incoherent
stuff
now speaking of old politicians
there is a politician who has been in
the united states senate since before
ronald reagan was inaugurated for the
first time
that man's name is chuck grassley
senator from iowa
oldest republican in the senate
88 years young he's served for seven
terms already and he just announced that
he's running for reelection
hey there i'm running for re-election
it's the right thing to do for iowa
i have an unpopular opinion is everyone
saying oh he's too old we need term
limits we need to stop these old people
from
running for office
i have an unpopular opinion but here it
is
i love that he's running for reelection
i think it's great good for him
he's relatively relative compared to
other senators he's relatively quite a
stalwart conservative
on pretty important political issues he
has stood up
at crucial moments not at every moment
but at crucial moments he stood up he's
obviously still pretty fit he's far more
coherent than joe biden even though he's
got 10 years on joe biden
good for him
i'm glad he's doing it and if he does
step down at some point
they'll just appoint another republican
to take his place
it won't be any sort of bruising
election there
and uh and if he gets to be 90 94
and he runs for election again or i
guess he's i guess he'd be what
95 i don't know he'd be up there then
good for him
by the end of his next term he'll be 100
something years old
good for him i think it's fine i'm i'm
pretty against
term limits the reason i'm against term
limits is because term limits do not
empower the people they empower the
staff members and the lobbyists and the
bureaucrats
okay the senators are supposed to be
elected by the states then the 17th
amendment change that they're elected
directly by the people
which did
change for the worse or system of
government or checks and balances but
then the people elect the senators
nobody elects the bureaucrats nobody
elects the permanent staff of the
committees nobody elects the lobbyists
and those are the people who are going
to have more power
the less power that the senators have so
i think fine chuck rassle is basically a
good republican senator good for him
we're not supposed to like him
in no small part because he's an old
white man an old white man are the worst
people on earth according to our modern
culture
well speaking of famous old white guys
the the new group of white men who are
being cancelled
are it's not the republican senators
it's not uh the
conservative celebrities
it is the
the jedi
from star wars it's like luke skywalker
that they're the ones who are being
canceled
there's a piece out
called why the term jedi is problematic
for describing programs that promote
justice equity diversity and inclusion
so these social justice warriors have
been referring to themselves as jedis
you know comparing themselves to the
star wars heroes uh because of justice
equity diversity and inclusion but this
article says no they're not because the
jedi
they're they're
straight white men and they're actually
defending the patriarchy and whatever i
mean this is a largely it's star wars
has a problematic cultural legacy
that has been critiqued for trafficking
and sexism racism and ableism
and you know princess leia in that
bikini was too sexy so that's bad and
it's got there's an orientalist subplot
and it's oh my gosh do you know where
this article was written
you would expect it to be written in
the most radical left journal right
mother jones salon.com i don't know
this article comes from scientific
american
scientific it brings us right back to
the top of the show
the way that
science
has been twisted in our culture
is to
be a religion
but there some religion is true
the difference here is that science is
being used to promote a false religion
this false weird creepy kooky shamanism
where we all have to be disciples and
apostles of dr fauci and the mayor of
the governor of new york and the libs
and the
the doctrines of science are not
permanent fixed laws they're just
capricious whims
of the various
shamans of this religion
and they change day by day by day this
is what science means and i know a lot
of right-wingers say well look i defend
science but i don't support scientism or
i support science i want to follow the
science it's
science doesn't mean
that anymore okay the left is redefining
that word too to try to redefine reality
this is a strange
creepy cult
on the left and we are not going to win
by playing along with their premises we
are going to have to talk about
about more basic things in our politics
justice
true liberty tradition
the way of life what it is that we want
to preserve
okay that is what we need to offer the
left has a very aggressive religious
view and it sweeps up a lot of people
what vision
are we offering if the only vision we
can offer is hey leave me alone hey you
do you
let's let's all just do whatever we want
to do if that's if that's the vision
we're offering we're going to continue
to lose i'm michael nolan's michael
knowles you'll see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show